what's going on guys he's just kicked
off
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's up
how's everybody doing it's been a little
while since we've done one of these it's
been a little while since we've done one
of these since we've done a live stream
it's been a bit what up old man oh man I
look so fat in this video and look I
just looked like I've got like like I'm
just some Mountain right I just got like
a a tiny head it's like this big ol body
oh no oh man what's up guys I'm actually
just using the the videomic pro the rode
videomic pro for the microphone on this
one so the recording mics actually over
there you guys want to see that you guys
want to see something cool
check this out maybe you can see it you
can hopefully hold on you guys are
probably kind of see it you can't really
make it out to clearly if I cover my
face maybe you can there you go alright
so so the salerio I've got it on on face
on my own face detection okay so so
ignore that pile right there I'm
currently in the process of getting my
office and everything cleaned up but um
yeah so this is my office now this is
where I work out of now it's cool and I
like it I got my face again it's cool I
I dig it I I like it I enjoy it you know
it's it's I think it looks good I think
it looks really really good
so um but yeah so how's everybody doing
why is this buffering two minutes in and
my stream is buffering that's a problem
there we go um but yeah so you hate my
voice you're not the only one I hate my
voice to you yeah the room setup is
pretty dope it's definitely definitely
good but
[Laughter]
okay what are we talking about today
what are we talking about today
um how do I get my hair cut I had more I
give me a one and a half all the way
around I'll be honest with you guys I've
had a very rough last couple days yeah
as you guys know I struggle with some
personal things and those kind of got
the better of me I have more ayah here
to help me basically get my [ __ ]
together or get my to get myself
together but uh but yeah so well I can
guarantee this is not gonna go on the
hashtag with me video from YouTube but
uh but yeah so um what's goin good
let's go I'm pretty good I slice goin
pretty awesome right um I taught you a
whole lot about this something superior
robbed forever yes all the people who
are gonna be fans on the superior robbed
are gonna be referred to as the superior
robbed core that's what you guys are
gonna be so who's in the background no
let's spider-man spider-man and Superman
sure those two people are uh who I think
should play Doctor Doom vincent cassell
I would say vincent cassell should play
Doctor Doom he'd be an amazing doctor
Tim so um what do I think about for max
it's all of the for Vikings story I mean
it was okay it was brutal it was exactly
what you would expect from like a Marvel
max uh a you know a four story but it
was good you know it was you know wasn't
the best story ever told but it was a
story finding a bunch of Vikings ahhmm
be so kind of weird but you know with
muffled actually got to a point where it
wasn't really about the the adult orient
to the imprint so much as it was just
telling stories that nobody there Marvel
wouldn't let anybody write anywhere else
it's really what it turned into
right so it was it was kind of nuts but
but yeah so mid need space yes we do
it's hard to talk about farts I'm not
gonna talk about farts all right let's
let's let's let's get this this chat
under control right let's do this chat
in control let's scroll up a bit
see if we can to find some things to
talk about
some questions uh let's see
cursing is fine um okay I already answer
that what do I think about throwbacks
what's my opinion on a spider-man
Wolverine I just I just missed it I just
lost it where was it
there's so many of you talking there's
so many people talking it's it's kind of
nuts um okay yeah our connection is good
okay what do I think about a moral Hulk
um it won't look as good but I can tell
just by what's going on in the current
arc before you know all this pandemonium
hidden and they stopped shipping comics
I can tell it's gonna be one of those
runs where it's gonna be hit and miss
there's gonna be arcs in there that I
absolutely adore and there's gonna be
arcs in there where it's like what was
al Ewing even thinking like you know
that's what it's gonna turn into we're
just fine because that's usually most
writers run that's one of the things to
keep in mind guys when it comes to like
full-on runs right you hear runs of like
Roy Thomas you hear like Walt Simonson
store run you hear all these different
things the reality of this is that in
every single one of those runs
they had like arcs that were just not
very good or not very enjoyable for
whatever reason that that you didn't you
wouldn't enjoy or I would enjoy whatever
they kate says no one's ever written an
entire comic book based on a character
that was 100% hit and never missed the
only exception to that was Jonathan
Hickman when he wrote Avengers New
Avengers and Fantastic Four and Brian
Michael Bendis as New Avengers and Chris
Claremont saxman and peel the Peter
David and Bill Matt Lowe's okay there's
been a few there's been a couple there's
there's been a few comics a coffee doug
ville it's the man he's pulling out of
old school how many of you guys remember
comics and coffee from like like what is
it three years ago like three or four
years ago how many of the guys remember
that I'm curious yeah this chats going
in
all right this chat this chat is like
hand not only is it delicious but you
can go in and we're hearing that job
from jenna Marbles like like seven years
ago so
um yeah it's kind of nuts uh what do I
think about Wally being the new dr.
Manhattan um honestly I think it's just
them figuring out what they're gonna do
until they figure out what they want to
do with Wally West because I think DC's
in a bit of a predicament right like
Geoff Johns brought back Barry Allen and
it's like Barry Allen's of Flash now and
and it's like okay but like what about
Wally West Barry Allen's the flash now
this is not a talking point it's not up
for discussion this is the way it is and
so I think it was kind of okay but like
fans want Wally West so they brought
back classic Wally West and I think he
came back with a little bit of fanfare
I'm like it came back with as much
fanfare as people expected him to well
you didn't get like a Wally West flash
book which is actually smart on DC not
to not to split it I think you can do
that in some instances like when they
did a Hal Jordan and the Green Lantern
Corps and then Green Lantern's that was
smart that was super smart a DC rebirth
was was firing on all cylinders when it
first launched I don't know what
happened I don't know what happened with
DC rebirth okay you know what I got some
rants what I want to go on here guys
I've got some rants that I want to go on
here anybody want to hear any rants
anybody want to hear any rants anybody
at all I'm kind of curious chaos King
versus the marquee of death the marquee
of death by Amaro um what I cover the
Messiah War storyline yes actually I
would love to cover that that is a good
story
um calories II coffee was the best how
far behind is the chat that's what I
wanna know I asked that question like
three minutes ago like I asked that
question a while ago Oh like is the lag
really bad just to make sure it's like
really bad lag is it I hope not I really
hope it's not um let's see it's my my it
was okay um what's going on this is how
much explain and this is my master class
uh Oh a small movie yeah I'm hyped for
this one movie
thoughts on superboy-prime returning
well he's been back for a while but he
having flashes a mirror which is like
the biggest cliffhanger ever right like
like I'm reading Shazam
and then it's just like okay this is
gonna be really cool and then it's like
it's like okay you know superboy-prime
is back and I'm super excited and then
it's like Corona fires and it's like
nobody gets new comics and it's like but
like Shazam was about to come back it's
like yeah I know sorry man sorry about
your luck this chat this chat is so far
behind me it's it's kind of nuts do I
have like slow-mo on like slow mode on
or something I'm kind of curious let me
double check here real quick because if
I have slow mode on then that would that
would that would explain why that and
the fact that I'm on I am on what you
wanna call it
I want edge here let me switch over to
Google Chrome let me switch over to this
resource hog this beast this thing is
this thing is kind of nuts hopefully
it'll be a little bit faster let's let's
log in here let's log and remove the
keyboard out of the way so you guys
can't see me I know what y'all are doing
you're not fooling me you can't pull the
wool over my eyes people are saying yes
to a rant yes to a rant people are
saying yes to a rant let's rent I don't
understand I don't understand what
happened with DC Comics somebody
explained to me what happened with DC
Comics I don't understand this right
like like DC launched the new 52 and the
new 52 was just a colossal nightmare of
a situation okay Newton if it was even
that bad well I never did to you like
for me and if you did here was someone
enjoyable because it gave me the ability
to enter into DC Comics I'll give them
that but then we started getting stories
like like not forever evil which one was
it
um which one was a really bad one
futures end we got futures and we got
stories like that but DC we burned like
like
we're kind of getting frustrated people
get a year 10 asleep okay cool so DC
starts winding down they start you know
they start year enough for DC rebirth
and everybody is excited for DC rebirth
because we're gonna start getting back
getting getting stories on characters
that have been gone for a long time a
really good example is Wally West right
Wally West was gone he was out of the
picture and and people wanted like the
old-school red haired Wally West to come
back and that made perfect sense because
if you were reading comics back from
like 1993 you know all the way running
up until like 2011 you were reading
Wally West right like you were reading
that version of the flash and there was
no arguing that point right that's the
version of the flash that you were
reading the the issue was you had people
who got into Justice League and Justice
League Unlimited all right and they were
digging the whole idea of you know the
classic Wally West and the DC goes in a
new 52 classic Wally West is gone not to
be seen or heard from like it wasn't
seen that so that it wasn't like it was
after crisis on Infinite Earths right
after crisis on Infinite Earths Barry
Allen like he appeared a couple of times
and it's like okay cool so like Barry
Allen there he shows up for like a
little quick moment or so along those
lines and that's basically it
he was still dead after crisis he would
basically time displace from before when
you know before crisis happening but
like he was there and it was like okay
so like that works that's that's okay
but people got tied into the the red
haired Wally West so then we get into
dr2 new VD to red haired Wally West is
gone people are pissed DC is like okay
cool we'll bring him back we'll bring a
few other things back they had a
short-lived series like there are people
who said they want Maxwell Lord back why
nobody wanted Maxwell Lord back Maxwell
or didn't even want to come back nobody
wanted Maxwell Lord and so they they
brought back they they brought back red
haired Wally West DC would be birth
kicks off the first thing we get DC
Universe rebirth number one Watchmen are
in there all this is gonna be legit it's
gonna be awesome so then like over the
course of I would say like a six to
seventh month period DC we birth was
crushing I don't even say 6 to 7 months
I'd say a year for a year DC was rushing
it right like like do you guys remember
the meme like he does she has her birth
up mean what was what was the DC rebirth
mean guys what was a DC rebirth mean
what was the meme meme review meme
review
what was the mean right the best thing
coming out of DC rebirth that was the
mean right
that was the mean that was the whole
idea it was just this this exactly the
best thing coming out of DC rebirth
Medora hasn't like that's that's exactly
what it was like it was it was
everything coming out was the best thing
coming out of DC rebirth do you guys
know how I used to start my videos right
like I'd cover Action Comics so Action
Comics is the best thing coming out of
DC rebirth and then like we go into the
Superman so Superman is the best thing
coming out of DC with how one of the
Green Lantern of course Green Lantern's
my Sam Humphreys like just everything
even Wonder Woman by greg rucka right
like everything coming out of rebirth
was just fire and it was it was it was
like to DC can't do anything wrong man
like DC can do no wrong this is amazing
all right fast forward two years what
happened that's what I want to know what
hap I'm like cable from that episode of
x-men the Animated Series win like they
all went to apocalypses temple and then
like then like you know like Xavier was
kidnapped everything went white right
like hey what comes walking in there
what happens like that's exactly what
that's that's where I am right like what
happened what happened you know and
here's this is the biggest issue that I
have you can never have Marvel and DC
both doing good at the same time right
like you never get that right if we
haven't had that in years and years and
years the only time I'd say we had that
was it was during the a during that era
of like Infinite Crisis right so we're
talking about between 2004 2005 running
up to about 2010 right like so so
Infinite Crisis final crisis like 52
week countdown like all these these
amazing stories of DC was coming out
with right let just these these awesome
stories you know Grant Morrison's entire
Batman run just like these these amazing
things and then like Marvel was doing
like Messiah Complex and Messiah War and
like Civil War and like like everything
was a war right like Marvel war and like
Captain America can't find the can't
find the toilet-paper war and like I a
man wants to drink again even though he
knows he shouldn't war like everything
was war but like you have like all these
these just amazing stories coming out of
both publishers but and it's just it is
and it's kind of like what happened but
I understand what happened with me
see and this light it's like you know me
I mean eventually they'll pull it
together right they always do like
Marvel Marvel okay here's the thing I
liked some of what Marvel was doing
coming in and coming out of all-new
all-different marvel my gripe with
all-new all-different marvel is it was
not all new and it was not all different
it was it was literally like old all the
same that you're familiar with Marvel
that's exactly what it was right like
like all the same not different Marvel
and like I was like when all this
leading all-new all-different marvel I
was expecting like a reboot right like
hip and set the stage for the whole
thing Hickman's like hey guys so here's
a story where the multiverse is
collapsing and there it goes
time to recreate it you know and the
missus like and everything's recreated
the exact same way it was before and
it's like no man like like I don't
understand that right like like I'm
alone I said we'll do a little enables
super chance here and it's like oh this
is like any old ads I give you
highlights that's cool anyway like I was
expecting a whole new reboot right I was
expecting like a whole reboot and we
didn't and we didn't we didn't had
toilet paper the best thing coming out
of quilted northern the best thing no I
can get their hands on um but yeah I
like like I was expecting a full-on
reboot right but kind of was like okay
you know whatever sort of sort of going
along and doing their thing and and like
didn't they they had so much strong well
as I had some super weak moments right
then we get into like Marvel legacy
right like we get Marvel generations
model now 2.0 that kind of stuff
it was just like busy stuff right it was
just like busyness and then didn't like
like axel Alonso is out right he's out
is like the the editor in chief Omar
what was just like get out right so they
they they get him out
they bring in CB Sapolsky a comic book
fan running a comic book company
well the wonders never cease like it
just started blowing up will the wonders
never cease right like it just started
and sort of do any exceedingly well
imagine that a comic book fan running a
couple of a company like it becomes a
great comic book humming they start
producing like all these amazing stories
and and they they have it I mean it's
not I'm not every story's great right
not every story solid but Marvel's
firing much better than they were before
and and my question is like what
happened with DC right like what
happened along the way right it just
kind of fizzled out and I think a few
things happened one watchman took way
too long Doomsday Clock it took way too
long
I get that there were some things going
on right Gary Frank had whatever it was
that he had going on and then you had
like cuz I see while the script writing
was done we were just waiting on Gary
Frank I don't really know why um I mean
I don't I don't know his his whole
situation Randall know him as a person I
don't know what he was going through
what he was dealing with so I don't know
you know why there were such extreme
delays but there were alright so a comic
that should have come out in one year
took three years by the time Doomsday
Clock ended there was interest in there
but only four people for the end that
people just wanted to see like Superman
fighting dr. Manhattan right because the
answer to the questions of everything
that comes out of that whole thing was
answered right then you go into like Tom
King's Batman run Tom Kings Batman run I
thought was great I thought one of the
biggest problems and it had his time it
was just basically Tom King patting
himself on the back and telling himself
how awesome he was and then you go into
heroes in crisis which is a great big
huge metatextual story they didn't have
any real significance whatsoever you had
you had um yeah joshua Williamson's
flash which was amazing and it's still
good but like DC does I mean DC just
exploded my Doomsday Clock or DC was
just it was a rocket just exploring and
then it just starts petering off and
coming coming down and I don't I don't
understand how well I don't understand
why somebody answer that for me I don't
understand why alright so next rent I
want to talk about digital versus
physical comic book sales and I'm
probably gonna piss off some fans
talking about this don't care so here's
here's the biggest issue that I have
here right here's the biggest the
biggest problem that I have here like I
don't understand why comics are not
being sold digitally but I don't
understand why that's not happening
right now right and from what I know I
do understand it from what I understand
what was going on here was that the
lease from Donnie Cates tweet Marvel
didn't want to like torpedo
brick-and-mortar stores right Marvel
didn't want to be like okay so I if we
just start releasing them all digitally
then the given I assume that the
discussion on the background was like
you know if we start releasing them
digitally now and then people will
realize I can get comics digitally and
they won't go to kind of bookstores
anymore so like we can't give them
digitally we got to make sure that comic
book stores say a lot okay so people
won't buy comic books physically they'll
only buy them digitally if they realize
that the digital contents they
so be the store that offers more than
comics you know what kind of stories
you're succeeding now in the kind of AG
landscape comic book stores that are not
selling just comics right like like
that's that's like that's like people
getting pissy and getting mad because a
store that only sold eight tracks went
out of business well of course they did
technology passed them by
and like the medium shifted to a new
medium and they just didn't keep up
sorry about your luck make better
choices next time that's how the
business market works I don't know what
to tell you guys right like I know what
to tell people now I do understand the
idea being able to physically hold pages
being able to turn pages and like okay
so here's a really good example this was
fantastic for issue number 48 right this
is the first appearance of Galactus
this is x-factor number what is its
number six this is the first appearance
of apocalypse and Marvel Comics this is
Fantastic Four annual number two this is
the original origin of Doctor Doom this
is giant-size x-men number one right
this is the this is like literally the
beginning right more or less the
beginning of Claremont's run right like
I buy physical if it matters right like
if it's significant if it if it has some
kind of meaning right and there's
[Music]
those are all comics right there and a
picture of me and Mariah and some art by
Donald Glover you know I'm not Donald
I'm some art bye bye hey Dominic Dominic
Glover right like like I buy physical
comics if they're a particular interest
or they're important right like like in
that in that that thing you're gonna
find like a secret empire that was
autographed to me and actually Sal
overcome pop gotta for me from from Nick
Spencer right like in that box you're
gonna find a copy of of what is it
the original oh my god what is it Todd
McFarlane's first a first cover on
spider-man you know one where you sit
all the way but all that kind of stuff
autographed by Todd McFarlane you're
gonna find an Iron Man comic autographed
by Stan Lee right like I buy things I
buy physical comics if they're
significant right but like I listen to
my music digitally I stream it i watch
my movies digitally I have a like maybe
10 4k movies down there because they're
particularly important right I'm not
gonna cut in my house up with physical
comics you know that's that's that I
don't do that anymore well I've kind of
moved I kind of move beyond that and so
my entire idea is okay if this is the
case if this is where the I mean like
yeah I mean I can I can grab a ball
oh these six issues of the century by
Paul Jenkins and Jay Lee right with the
with the tie-ins the century and
Fantastic Four number one the century
and spider-man number one all that stuff
like you guys like it when I flex on
here's here's all the Action Comics 1000
variant covers right that's all the
variants
is to rob thanks for the support
Nick Spencer right secret Empire like
down there you'll find CGC comics like
cGCC G seed Phoenix saga the the x-men
the Phoenix saga you'll find those damn
in there right like I've got I've got
what does I have the original what am i
what was that story so what were strife
kind of strife came back so I've
appeared for the first time took out
Xavier everybody thought it was cable
all that kind of stuff what was the name
of that story what was what was the name
of that story um yeah the the giant-size
x-men number one is autographed by
Jonathan Hickman um what was that story
not fatal attractions uh what was that
what was that story that's to go that
was secret Empire um wasn't even a story
guys the one with executioner song there
we go thank you thank you thank you so
much that was uh that was Sean Sean
Morton art Sean send me an email you get
a Rob four ring that's that's that's
that's what that was like that's that's
executioner song right I have the whole
original executioner song back there
right I have like I have all these
things I buy physical if it's
significant if it's important but the
reality of the world that we live in is
that if we're if comic book stores if
physical comic book stores are not
selling anything but physical comics in
a world that's increasingly becoming
digital then it's only a matter of time
before they die off right at this point
the the entirety of you know strictly
comic book store selling comic books
it's a laboring beast gasping for breath
and it should be allowed to die right
like let digital comics take its place
and let those stores who have invested
in things besides comics continue on
right this the comic book stores are
thriving the ones that are doing fine
the ones who are not going to these
great big huge events and like
complaining you know about how like you
know Marvel and DC are doing things that
are making it tough for them to
distribute so on and so forth right
those are the ones who are investing in
things like like tabletop games all that
kind of stuff right like I get the
notion of just like they sell comics and
they
we sell comics and like we should keep
them alive no we shouldn't write like
like this it doesn't really make any
sense to me to say that right when music
first went digital you guys remember all
the complaints about how like it was
impossible to sing songs to iTunes and
how difficult it was to get songs in an
iPod if you were just like this is
ridiculous and it's nonsense now it's
common practice and in fact you can
update you can literally sync stuck to
your phone through Wi-Fi right like
that's where we are a technology now it
just took a little while for people to
get onboard and so I have a hard time
believing that in an age when people are
are really when people are streaming
movies digitally when people are
listening to their music digitally
people are watching TV shows digitally
people how people are having
conversations digitally in that day and
in this day and age when digital content
is the name of the game I have a hard
time believing that that like you know
companies should go out of their way in
order to insure physical properties stay
alive do you is is there something
nostalgic about going into a comic book
store and buying a comic yeah but like
whenever I go in and this is the the
realities whenever I go into comic book
stores you know people always say well
you're gonna be killing the community
all that kind of stuff what community
like whenever I go into comic book
stores you know and I see like two
people in there at any given point in
time the only time I ever see anything
more than like five or six people in a
comic book store is on Wednesdays and
everybody's going in there and
everybody's giving their poles and then
they're leaving but they're never like
nobody's sticking around it's like hey
man you read the newest issue of
Avengers yeah man
dude it was it was great what did you
think well I mean I thought it was okay
no no it's not like every comic book
store is New York comic-con
you know I invested in an illusion you
guys have then let me let me a Swede you
of that illusion and let me remove that
illusion from your view that's not the
case right like that's that's not what
it is right like the community won't
wall will do just fine you know why
because like people are not taking their
physical comics and then going to like a
comic book club that's not really
happening right like I mean maybe in a
few places here and there but like
almost nowhere else is that happening
people aren't really like taking their
physical comics and going to the mall
and the food court and like sitting down
and talking about their comics this is
not 1994 but that's not what people
doing people are getting the newest
comics reading about them and then
talking about them on reddit right just
like you know reddit calm like already
calm because a new reddit sucks
already calm slash are slash slash
morbol and then like talking about it or
like slash comic books and then talking
about it
in the digital space right so you know
you know in my mind it's one of these
things where it's like you know should
we go out of our way to kill comic book
stores no but should we be doing
everything we can to keep them alive
no because the markets shift and the
markets change and it doesn't make any
sense to invest all this time and money
in keeping comic book stores alive if
they're not really even willing to
update with the Arizona even really
really willing to change with the time
they want to keep on living like just
1993 like they want to stay in 1983 I
when I lived in in in in Colorado right
when I lived in Loveland Colorado in
Fort Collins there was a comic book
store that myself and Sal went to I
don't even know it was there right I
just watched Jason's come to book store
all at home whenever I pulled my stuff
like whatever I whatever I was like
reading comics yeah like I would go on
comiXology and I was like if there's
something in particular that I want I'll
go to Jason's store and buy it because
it looks cool I just want the physical
copy of it but like like when when we
were in Fort Collins I was in town -
myself bin Isa all this were hanging out
Benny and they were off doing their own
thing I don't they were playing Pokemon
ago or something like that
me and Sal were like whatever man let
them do their thing we went to this
comic book store with a green front we
stepped into that thing and it was like
this store that time forgot it was just
like a throwback to like 1993 I think I
had posters in there that were like
faded right now Jason's store is updated
right Jason store is newer and it's
modern it looks like a comic book store
it feels like a comic book store but in
the middle of the story you know what
they have tables and they have like
Magic the Gathering games and they have
like Star Wars tabletop and they have
all kinds of things for people to do
besides go in there and buy comics why
because that's beginning to move away
and people aren't going into stores and
buying comics at least I don't imagine
as frequently as they used to and if
they are it won't last that way forever
people are going to want to go and get
digital comics right digital sales it
makes sense because for me if I'm
traveling like when I was going to New
York Comic Con or when I went to San
Diego comic-con or I went to Rhode
Island or Baltimore or any of those
places I didn't want to lug around like
20 individual floppies right I don't
want to take my backpack and have like a
whole
pack filled with treats just to have
something to read on the flight no I
would read them all digitally right
because all I need is an iPad pro all I
need where's my iPad pro all I need is
this right here and I've got thousands
of comic books right so the reality is I
understand that there's this desire to
keep these these you know these these
old school stores alive I understand
there's like this nostalgia that kind of
goes into it but the reality of the
situation is that the market is shifting
right the markets shifting the markets
changing people need to start people
people need to and will start getting on
board with digital comic book sales and
when that happens
physical comics are gonna start to go
away right they're gonna start to
transition they'll always be there you
can always find a record store you can
always find an 8-track store but you can
always find those things where you can
find out all over the place that were if
there was one of four columns all they
did was sell like records right you
could go in there buy record you could
buy like Dark Side of the Moon
right I like Pink Floyd you can go by
like Beatles records if you wanted to
pay all the money they were wrong there
they were gonna charge you for it you
could find thriller behind the shelf you
could find a lot of these really old
records but those are specialty stores
now they're not this standard they're
not a music store anymore it's a
specialty store that you go to for
something in particular and they may or
may not be able to get their hands on it
for you right so like that's that's
that's the thing for me right like like
the the the idea for me is I understand
this idea to keep kind of book stores
alive but I feel like people are caught
up in their feelings they're caught up
in their feelings and they're caught up
in their nostalgia and they're not
really able to to look alike to take
away take a break away from the reality
of the situation and say like if the
entirety of the world is moving more and
more towards digital content then like
why not comic books right you pretty
much stream everything else
why shouldn't you stream comic books as
well right that's just this that's
that's kind of the nature of the beast
right and it's one of these things I
hear people say stuff like well if I
have a physical comic then comiXology
can't shut off my access to it okay well
what's your justification for Netflix
because like at any point in time they
can shut off your access to Netflix ah
well that's different
you know what's your justification for
using like Apple TV or like Amazon Prime
video or any of those anyone
those streaming services out there if
the argument that you have is well they
can shut off my access to those comics
at any point in time then you should
only be buying physical movies and
physical video games and all that kind
of stuff you should only be buying those
physical things to make sure that your
access to them never gets cut off so
like you know they do but but that's the
thing like it's it's it's it's
interesting to me you know like this is
interesting to me not only that and
here's usually other thing that I think
needs to happen I'm big on board if we
are gonna keep physical stores alive
then move away from individual
individual comics but comic books this
is a gripe that I've had for years
it's a gret that I've had for years
because I feel like individual trade or
individual floppies in this day and age
right like this in this day and age runs
people off of comics it pushes people
away from comic which you wouldn't know
why because it's already walked up to me
right now and they say Rob I want to
start reading spider-man where should I
read then I would say okay start with
all-new all-different amazing spider-man
okay cool so they start with all-new
all-different amazing spider-man ah but
I don't understand like what's Parker
industries where does that come from
well yeah you got to read superior
spider-man if you want to know what
that's about
okay well okay what's this doctor
occupied what it is all like people
who's who are these kids okay yeah you
probably got to start with with Dan
Slott spider-man Big Time you know so
literally you got to start back in like
2005 you know or you can you can just
kind of jump back you can you can jump
to the old closer and just sort with
like the beginning of Nick Spencer's run
but the issue you run into you with
single issues is it gets to a point
where it's almost just not even
cost-prohibitive I mean it is but it's
not even cost-prohibitive it's just
organizationally it's impossible to try
to keep track of right like it's it's
ridiculously difficult to do my
philosophy is they should just go with
quarterly trades that's what they should
be doing released trades everything
every quarter right like just do it
every three months
just just release like a single story
arc every three months and that's it
right now you don't do like you'll do
like one giant Neil the Marvel book of
comics you know once once every three
months they don't know you get like the
trade for Fantastic Four you get a trade
for this a trade for that a trade for
that so on and so forth but it's just a
singular story arc you know and if it's
going to be one of these where it takes
like you know six issues I'm like you
just do it all within the within the
spent yeah just in that one tree right
it's just it's not like the trader
loaded so like what would be one issue
for a month for that three months now if
they do monthly or anything like that
like you just
the entire story arc in that one tray
prevent a tree paper back and that's it
and then what happens is you have people
who come in and they say okay so like
I'm gonna get into spider-man like where
do I begin okay by those ten trade
paperbacks don't buy those 250
individual issues that you have to read
all of in order to understand what's
going on if you tell people just read
ten trade paperbacks Wow
I mean we can read that at night before
they go to bed as opposed to giving them
the stack that high of single individual
comics that they have to read right like
that's that's ridiculous right and
that's that's why I like I've I've I've
I've idli been against in a lot of ways
the notion of keeping individual
floppies alive like I think that like it
needs to transition to trade paperbacks
and just strictly trade paperbacks and
then really nothing nothing else because
I think it's I think it's it's it's
normal but I'm not a real collector I
just have comics in my house I mean I
guess I'm not a real collector insofar
as I'm a person who purchased a comic
because it has value to me I collect it
and I hold on to it if what you're
talking about is the notion of like
buying comics and then selling them for
a profit if that's what you do well then
people like you almost kill the comic
book industry in the 1990s oh no I don't
want to be a part of that community I
don't want to be a part of the community
that has a record of almost killing the
comic book industry in the 90s I don't
want to be part of that like buying and
selling comics that's not my thing right
like to me if I'm gonna buy a physical
comic it needs to mean something right
like Jonathan Hickman saying you know
signing a giant-size x-men issue number
one it's made out to me I'm never gonna
sell that that's ridiculous but I don't
know I'm just saying like it's just it's
just my you know just just my rant on
that you know treats for the wind so but
yeah so even let's say with more than 30
minutes and you're still not an expert
okay what should I explain like what am
i what am I gonna explain what am I
gonna explain to you guys what am I
gonna make you an expert on one of my
thoughts on the end of dance flops run
in spider-man I loved and fought
spider-man run I know a lot of you I
know it had a head like a really mixed
response and I know that there were were
people who weren't really huge on it
like I know that that superior
spider-man got a lot of
I love superior spider-man I thought was
one of the best spider-man stories ever
right like I absolutely loved it but ya
know so so so yeah that comic have some
X let's see I asked you a regulated
Thanos dude dude astral regulator Thanos
let me tell you something man
I didn't know who he was right and then
I was like okay like like because people
were just like hey Rob do a Beyond
omega-level video on Astro regulator
sales like I'm thinking of like oh so
he's got like coronavirus right and like
he's got he's got one of those breasts
mash things on you know and it's like
some fan comic just like a play on
things you know like like be really
topic Oviatt 19 what's he gonna do he's
gonna get the Infinity Gauntlet and snap
it away yeah I didn't I didn't know I
didn't know what it was okay okay so I
sit down and read it dude let me tell
you something man like this is Jay this
is what this is the story jim Starlin
wanted instead of donnie cases Thanos
wins I think this story was a little
over the top and I think that the famous
wins by Donnie Cates was a lot more
reasonable and it was it was certainly
more in the vision of what Marvel's
writing like what one was doing overall
in terms of the tone and the feel that
they have but uh but no dude here's the
thing man Astro regulators Thanos puts
Infinity Gauntlet stano's to shame
through Infinity Gauntlet sounds do you
have anything on this guy it is nuts
it's ridiculous like the first half the
first thing that we did was just kind of
setting the stage right like there's
just setting the stage like what what
happens like the second part that comes
out tomorrow all just gonna be insane or
yeah it's nuts
it's absolutely bonkers right it's just
like it just didn't demolishes infinity
infinity war
Thanos right as you know Infinity
Gauntlet Thanos like it he cuts a swath
he cuts a swath that's exactly what he
does it's it's insane it's kind of nuts
but but ya know it's it's kind of
bonkers
you know it's cool but it's kind of
bunkers um what did I think about the
arrow versus crisis on Infinite Earths
like arrow in crisis one of editors he
becomes you know you guys know what
happens to him you know spoilers I guess
for a six-month old TV show but but um
Graham Morrison's Green Lantern run is
amazing Wow
well agree to disagree I feel like his
writing is OK the art is what turns me
off of his Green Lantern run that's what
turns me off okay I was reading the
first issue I didn't know what was going
on in the first issue I have no idea
what's happening right now it's just an
amorphous blob of colors and like some
black lines that are supposed to be
shapes like I don't know what's
happening right now I don't know my
shapes squares the circles and things I
don't know how that stuff works but like
it was I know my shapes it was it was
nuts but I should do a watch a long
Marvel anime series I think I might
start doing that on I'm like because
what does it twitch has that doesn't it
twitch or like Netflix or one of them I
think the the moderators on or the
admins of the moderators on dis quarter
looking into it but I feel like one of
those has that but can I see the five
x-men having their own comic series I
mean what would it be
it'd just be all of them just sitting in
a room continually resurrecting people
it'd be the most boring coming ever
previously on the five welcome back bro
welcome back girl good to see you again
left literally Adobe it'd be the least
interesting comic book story ever
um let's see one of my thoughts on dark
Hawk for Marvel never seen myself with a
guy I'm he's actually one of those
characters I am not at all familiar with
I don't know anything about I've never
researched him never looked into him or
anything
so doom signals those were amazing but
that's the thing man although all like
the best comics stopped because of this
right like Thor by Donny Cates stopped
Fantastic Four versus the x-men and it
looked like these were about to pop off
right stopped yeah like Geoff Johns
Shazam after like ten issues was finally
getting good stopped you know it's like
it sucks you know like I mean my comics
dies any of my comic book fix but the
new New Warriors save space people been
asking me about that for a long time the
new Marvel Zombies comment we got one
issue I don't think we're gonna get
anything more out of it I think it was
just kind of like Marvel just being like
I wonder what would happen if we just
did like I don't know I don't know what
it is but um why is the flash the
strongest it is the thing is as far as
I'm aware but what's going on Ryan I'm
doing good I'm doing good I appreciate
it but I have not read the new star with
the new Star Wars Darth Vader comic is
it as good as Karen Gillan's run because
Karen Gillan's run was amazing it was
very very good it was it was some of
them it was just across the board some
of the best kind of book reading that
I've seen in a long time
um let's see
please do a video on hella how did
buying and selling comics almost kill
the industry in the 1990s oh I honestly
don't understand history time okay so if
you are buying comics back in like the
40s 50s or 60s then like the only real
option you had if you wanted to sell it
was your local comic store you
the bookstore in your local town and you
would say okay I'm gonna get as an
expert by the way we are or how far are
we into this thing we're 45 minutes into
the video now I'm gonna make you an
expert on how the comic book industry
almost died in the mid 1990s actually
how it led to the birth of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so yeah so if you
were buying comics in the 40s 50s and
60s and you bought your comic and you
wanted to sell your comic you had to go
to your local comic book store and the
amount of money you would give for your
comic was relative to how many people
were asking for it right so like if you
live out in in the middle of nowhere
okay um if you if you live out in the
middle of nowhere and and you have a
copy of like DC showcase number four
right the first appearance of Barry
Allen right you have that you have that
that that comic yeah DC showcase number
four I think was over for was number
four number five which one was I guys
I'm pretty sure it was DC DC showcase
number four but anyway you had your the
copy a DC showcase number four and you
wanted to sell that to your local comic
book store then if nobody was coming in
and asked me for that comic you would
get pennies for it well you would get
virtually nothing it's a Bible a comic
book if it was it was drawn all-new
all-different Bible a Bible rebirth um
but uh let's see yeah I have a full view
well I have a video about earth I do not
have a video about universe FX or
paradise X and I actually need to cover
those I need to cover both of those
stories but anyway you were you were
left to your local comic book store
right so um all this changed in like
1971 when this guy named Overstreet
created something called the over
Overstreet price guide and the idea was
the Overstreet price guide and tell you
how much your coming book was worth
locally it told you how much your comic
book was worth nationally and so what
that meant is you had a bargaining chip
now right you could walk into your local
comic book store and you could say I got
a copy of DC showcase number for the
first appearance of Barry Allen it's in
mint condition
I want like I don't know how much oh how
much a lot of money is back in the neck
in 1970 like 1971 will say like hey you
wanted what Leonore like 50 bucks I
guess was a lot of money back
I don't know about the currency exchange
and inflation all that kind of stuff but
like also you want like a good chunk of
change whatever amounts to like a
thousand dollars today you know or
really be worth more than that I'd be
worth you know Tim's of thousands so
let's say you wanted like like thirty
thousand dollars for it you know in
today's currency uh your local bookstore
would say no I'm not gonna give you that
because nobody's in here asking for it
you can say yeah but like you know
there's there's people and you know it's
worth that much in like California but I
just can't find it in California right
or you could write to a person who was
looking for a comic in California well
you could just write to them you know
call them something like that call him
up or whatever the case is but
communicate with them and find a way to
get that give that exchange going but
basically you could you could sell your
comment to people on other other sides
of the country and people started to get
a fair understanding of how much their
comics were worth but what this did is
it led to people coming to this
realization and that comic books that
had particular particularly notable like
first appearances right so like DC
showcase number four the first
appearance of of Barry out um quality
comics number one the first appearance
of Quicksilver the character that would
go on to be renamed as Max mercury under
Mark Twain's flash like All Star Comics
number one right or like you know all
like more fun comics number one right
you know like like new new was a new fun
comics number one the first real comic
book made by Malcolm wheeler-nicholson
like if you had if you had those people
realized they were worth a lot of money
well like they'd be worth a ton of money
right like you know their granddad or
their dad may have bought it for like
ten cents and they can sell it for like
20 grand right so it's like well dude if
this is this is the case like I can buy
all kinds of comics and then sell them
later right that combined with the
popularity the increasing popularity of
comics led to like all these comic book
stores exploding up all over the place
right so yeah like all these kind of
resource popping up and then you have
the collector market starting to boom
right people were like buying comics and
then selling comics they were just
buying and selling buying and selling
behind selling and buying so the issue
with this is that local comic book
stores didn't tell Marvel in DC and and
even like died in comics by the time
1990 1990 91 92 came around they weren't
telling them we sold a million copies of
x-men vol 2 issue number one and like
people were coming in and buying like
five at a time
right
they just sold they just said we sold a
million copies of X been valued to issue
number one give us more
and so what Marvel and DC weren't aware
of her presumably weren't being told
about is that people were going out and
they were basically buying more than one
comic and then wanting to turn and sell
it now a lot of it also kind of reached
the ears of Marvel in DC just by virtue
of being kind of book publishers there's
no way they couldn't have known but what
it meant is that because they realized
that like people were buying up tons and
tons of comics they started making tons
and tons of comics and so you started
getting things like fatal attractions
where you started giving the fatal
attraction storyline you get like
Wolverine issue number wherever RIA
whatever it is 45 whatever is whereas
adamantium it gets ripped out of his
body
and you get like like like like what is
it those reflective covers you get all
these Democratic covers you had the
death of Superman you get like twelve
covers right you get like 12 different
covered books the books the twelve
different covers people were buying them
like hot cakes because the belief was
the value of comics would rise
exponentially and it would rise forever
until it didn't because people started
coming to this realization okay so
spider persona so the Superman dies in
the death of Superman I have this comic
and so does everybody else that I know
and the comic book stores sold out of it
and they're running into like second
third and fourth printing so like
everybody has this comic so it's not
worth as much because everybody has it
and then they started looking around and
they started asking questions like well
wonder how like what other comics I have
that everybody else has and people sort
of come into this realization they
weren't the only ones that came up with
the genius idea of buying the comic you
know of buying crisis on Infinite Earths
because it can be worth a lot of money
everybody had that idea which meant that
like everybody had a copy of it and what
you're gonna do you're gonna sell
somebody so they sell to a person so
they have two copies it's not gonna
happen right so like nobody could really
move product they couldn't really move
the Comets that they were buying so they
just stopped buying them because they
didn't really have any dies like well I
mean if this isn't gonna be worth any
things I'm not gonna buy it right and
what it did is it led to this you know
people created this artificially
inflated coming book market and then
they just stopped buying comics and it
ain't right like it almost totally
destroyed the industry marvel by that
point had long since been sold by
cadence industries right from from
Martin Goodman who owned that company
like they had long since been sold like
hiddens industries they didn't really
have anybody back in DC had been bought
by Warner Brothers a long
before that's right so if DC was
struggling financially they had Warner
Brothers to basically bail them out so
long as there was light at the end of
the tunnel right so long as Wonder
brothers could look to the horizon and
say okay you're gonna start making money
again right because like if you're not
then we are gonna cut you loose and it's
like no no we'll start making money
again everything will be okay right you
know so Marvel didn't have that well
then here comes Ike Perlmutter and an
avi arad from toy biz you know and
they're like okay like we'll financially
help to bail these guys right so they
basically they bankrolled Marvel for
quite some time that's where you
starting in a Marvel Knights because
what you had you had Joe Quesada who
came on you know with with Jimmy call me
Ani they had event publications they
released they did Marvel Knights
basically printing and like writing
stories about the characters it just
didn't sell that's why you saw like
Marvel Knights Black Panther Marvel
Knights daredevil Punisher things like
that because they were considered the
unsalables
nobody wanted their comics nobody really
wanted their stories a few people did
but they just weren't really selling
that well back then and so that led to
Joe Quesada becoming editor-in-chief at
the at the behest of Perlmutter and avi
arad I think I'm not gonna swear to that
but I'm pretty sure I led to him
becoming editor-in-chief in the early
2000s and then with the financial
backing of toy biz Marvel had that huge
explosion right so that's where you got
like a hassle em and that's where you
got Avengers disassembled and that's
where you got like what is it like like
New Avengers and you got like the x-men
decimation and like everything that came
after spider-man one more day like this
holy this whole reworking of everything
going on right like you you did have
Grant Morrison who was brought in and
like 2001 for a new x-men but even then
trying to maintain control and manage
like that many mutants and Marvel seemed
unruly so that's why casada was just
like just reduce the number down just
call it a day right I mean you had yet
well you had Grant Morrison's run then
he had Chuck Austin's run but
nonetheless you know that goes into the
desire for Marvel to start producing
their own movie so they took out a loan
from Merrill Lynch for like five hundred
million dollars put a whole bunch of
properties on the line but that's why I
like Sony owns all the spider-man
properties is because in the midst of
that of that crash you know that they're
kind of a collectors caused in the myths
of that crash Marvel was trying to stay
afloat stay afloat as best they could so
they sold off the film rights so like
the x-men the Fantastic Four spider-man
and all the related properties to like
Sony and Fox you know so that's why they
owned a whole bunch of those Universal
also I think took name with a Submariner
and
Incredible Hulk but that's why they
that's why you got all those movies out
there right you got like New Line Cinema
and blade right you got like you know
the the Eric Bana Incredible Hulk movie
by Universal Pictures right you got like
the x-men from Fox spider-man from Sony
because Marvel sold them off because
they were trying to stay afloat right
they put a whole bunch of other
properties on the line like Thor
shang-chi stuff like that with Merrill
Lynch like if they couldn't pay that
money back with Iron Man 1 then like
they were all gonna go bill yeah
fortunately for us
Iron Man 1 was a huge success otherwise
Marvel probably would have gone
completely bankrupt but yeah I mean
that's that's that's why I think the
rights reverted back um but that's why
you have this scenario where where I
don't want to be part of that market
that buys comics and then sells them
sells colleagues because like I watch
that go down but like I lived through
that that that era of comics when like
it all started to go belly-up I was like
11 11 or 12 years old at the time you
know not great I wasn't as old as a lot
of people were but like you know I
remember watching all that go down and
and I don't want to be a part of a
community that almost killed the comic
book industry because I love comic books
right so so that's that's why I'm not
really a big fan of being part of the
collector market but um I don't know if
Kevin Smith bought namor the sub-mariner
at any point in time but but yeah that's
more or less what it was you were 30 at
the time I was 30 ma'am that's nice um
no I haven't read any of this Marvel
Comics honestly I wasn't even really a
big fan of spider-man until I started
reading reading Dan Slott spider-man 1 I
started reading that like two years ago
right so it's only been recently that I
became spider-man College yeah I don't I
don't I do not collect comics with the
intention of selling them I collect
comics with the intention of keeping
them because they have value to me and
maybe like passing them on to my kids or
something along those lines you know but
but you know that's the thing you know
by the time I'm but I'm an adult you
know my kids aren't really gonna be no
but um I have kids my how my kids are
old enough to appreciate comics ah
they're not really gonna be reading
comics you know physically and I'll even
steer them away from that I'll be like
you should read them digitally like just
read them on your on your tablet on your
iPad that way you have like all the
comics
the world you're not cluttering up my
house while your comics you know like
like that kind of a thing cuz I love you
guys notice I mean it suck on that I
keep a pretty clean and like
aesthetically pleasing pleasing you know
space all over the place so aside from
this desk area that I need to clean up
and that what you might call that you to
clean up so um
random yes but is that an OG Gameboy yes
it is come on say this is an original
Gameboy and it does work here check this
out I'll have these batteries charging
so let's turn it on I kill those
batteries you spit
I forgot how terrible the battery life
on this thing is because I haven't
played with an original Gameboy for
years and years and years but okay can
you guys see that oh you guys can see
that but it works
it's nice game Ginny oh crap
let the game out put the game genie what
do I have in here right now oh yeah I
got Star Trek The Next Generation here
don't judge me alright let's turn it on
there we go Nintendo
[Music]
yeah it works pretty well huh
you get the game genie code screen
Codemasters
it's kind of nuts it's this this takes
me back to my childhood right
that game was dope flexing on people
with my old-school game boy man but yeah
this thing works that and the batteries
were always tough to get out of here
yeah how much of a pain in the ass
oh I will say this you guys want to talk
about a battery hog you guys remember
the old game gear of the game gear from
back in the day
that thing was a battery hog but yeah
that's an original Gameboy
pretty cool huh you know you guys won't
know how I got it
I know the story about how I got it I
love what to tell you guys you feel old
look into that yeah so do i I mean I
remember the old Atari I know I've got
fans here who remember the old Commodore
64 so I know some of y'all are old
people so I know some of you guys
remember the old Commodore 64 from back
in the day ps4 oh yeah I'm gonna say ps4
it uh let's see what's the story a buddy
of mine just gave it to me he called me
up he's like hey man you want old
gameboy I was like uh I mean how old are
we talking like a gameboy color or
gameboy advance he's like no man like
the original Gameboy I was like like the
green screen the gray text and he's like
yeah and I was like yeah man
what's he get oh I already made
everybody an expert on how chemical
collectors almost killed the industry in
the 1990s and these are the ones who are
complaining because Marvel and because
the industry is moving towards digital
promise
you really gonna let people who killed
almost killed accountable chemistry in
the 1990s decide what direction the
industry should go I'm gonna throw the
best judge for that but of course were
the best people to decide what direction
they come in look industry should go in
really the ones who almost killed it so
do i watch Star Trek Oh Oh child Lord
child let me tell you something a Star
Trek I am by no means an expert but I
grew up watching The Next Generation I
were watching Deep Space nine I thought
Deep Space nine sucked until you got to
the Dominion Wars then it got good but
up until that point was boring it was
boring it sucked so but um thank you so
much for answering my question Rob makes
a lot more sense now no for have Nicolas
Nicolas and Legolas do omega-level
eobard thawne I really should he's very
powerful anymore XO man award I don't
really do valiant anymore how powerful
would hope be if he had Iron Fist
abilities and go world breaker if he was
world breaker with an iron fist did he
punch the planet in half
Deep Space nine is not the best no it's
not in what universe would anybody
believe that deep space 9 was the best
Star Trek show that's crazy talk
Generation X explained Generation X was
an x-men team that was led by Emma Frost
and it was resoundingly successful and
incredibly well-written and then in it I
feel like 110 issues that was back in
the day when comics ran for a hundred
some-odd issues they didn't do like they
do now and they just like canceling it
like 30 issues and then start over again
which kind of sucks you know like I miss
the days when they would do that when
they would have like they would be like
Iron Man by Dan Slott and then it would
just run for like a hundred some-odd 100
and you know like 150 200 issues or
something like that you know I kind of
missed that
they just keep shifting riders around to
different stories and things like that
where you're like Brian Michael Bendis
you know you're like you know he was
right everything you want to you know
avoid omega-level mutant you to was was
kind of he was kind of broken
he was pretty Opie but no I'm anti
cancelled I'm just saying like they
write they write comics for like 30
issues and then they cancel them
and it's kind of that's kind of what
goes on I mean the only comic that I
remember running well I mean more
recently it seems like they do that now
up until all-new all-different marvel I
mean you had on your man from bindus you
had well I been mrs. Iron Man was after
you had met fractions Iron Man which
wasn't that long actually I want to say
it was maybe how many arcs did he have I
know he had the five nightmares I think
he had maybe like six or seven arcs so
we'd say anywhere between 36 to 42
issues and then Kieron Gillen came on
here and Gillen wrote it for about six
or seven arcs that's about another 30 to
40 issue so yeah
leading up to about all-new
all-different marvel yeah you know they
they kind of rebranded them we created
them so I don't know but The Ultimates -
yeah do alternates - like Ultimates why
a Ewing was so good I wish they never
cancelled it was so incredibly good the
problem is that nobody was buying it
it's like Captain America's run by
Tallahassee Coates it's like the I'm
sorry Captain America by Tallahassee
Coates is like his you know kasi goats
run it was the best Captain America
story that nobody was reading it was it
was amazing it was so good and like
nobody was reading it which is really
disappointing but uh but yeah so it's
reading comics out of order a bad thing
no I mean it's not like no one's gonna
drag you into the street and shoot you
for reading comics out of a worker I
mean some super hardcore fans may shun
you but like you know those are those
are like the Sheldon Cooper fans
the ones who were just like there's my
way of doing things and in the wrong way
you guys know one let me tell you some
every comic book group but every kind of
book like like every kind of a friend
group has that one guy in it right you
guys know who I'm talking about
well and if you don't know who I'm
talking about that guy's probably you
but you know who I'm talking about guys
you guys know that it's like you guys
know that one friend right like if you
know who that friend is say yes right
you have to name them just say like like
yes I know who that friend is or I have
that friend just say yes because I know
you guys know who I'm talking about but
what was the Captain America series that
I was just talking about tallahassee
coats um he took over for Captain
America after secret Empire and it was
it was amazing so yeah the elitist fans
[Laughter]
I got that one Freddie's like that then
we got that everybody has that one
friend now without that one guy shows up
you snow a little funny sometimes and
then like when he shows up to the group
you just kind of gone oh I'm talking
about
everybody has that one friend oh man
that one guy okay what do we name that
guy did we call him Harold should we
name that guy Harold don't be a Harold
don't be a Harold guys like should we
call him Hal what name should we call
that guy right that that type of guy
right like basic white girls are named
Karen's right what do we call this guy
right what's this guys named Lane Harold
Fred calling Fred Fred would be lame
what happened to the Ultimate Universe
it was destroyed during the events of
Secret Wars secret wars by Jonathan
Hickman 215 Brian Michael Bendis bro
back at the end of our time into and
then model didn't care because business
was leaning so Marvel was like anything
business is done gets triggered from the
record books it was rough
oh yeah they come they kind of loose a
Hubert Jax Nick Frank I like Harold
we're gonna go with Harold right no
Eugene is a good one yeah don't be a
Eugene now don't be a Harold I like here
they just rolls off the time better
don't be a Harold right don't be a
Harold I'm asically go it was like a
live stream you know if this is an
actual video video but well yeah don't
be a Chuck but my name is Carol like I
feel I feel like there's gonna be that
that one person like if I if I say like
right now don't be a Harold because
Harold sucks like there's gonna be
somebody who joins in like right at that
moment like that's the first thing
they're gonna hear don't be a hero
because Harold sucks like well then
screw you man
[Laughter]
but um okay guys uh Harold put on some
what did I say here go put on some
damned you owner yeah okay okay here's
that question how many of you guys know
that one kind of like phantom smells
funny it's like okay okay here's here's
what here's the thing I used to be that
no I never was but I have fancy word you
just who smell a little off poor Harold
oh poor Harold typical Harold Oh nope
Sean slaughter said me but uh okay guys
want me to go ahead and bounce off here
I'm gonna go ahead and bounce off here
and and yeah it's been cool talking to
you guys
it's been cool talking to you guys
and I'll catch you all later purse